I couldn't stop thinking about strawberry mochi ice cream
since I finished my last batch a few days ago
and since it's summer and berries are so good right now,
I decided to take full advantage of that.
Started by chopping up my strawberries
and letting them sit with some sugar
while I got started on my ice cream base.
Combine some milk, heavy cream, vanilla,
some sugar and gave that a really good mix.
I set that aside,
blended up my strawberries and then combined that with my milk mixture.
Once that was all incorporated,
I chilled that for about an hour
before pouring it into my ice cream Turner
and letting it turn for about 20 to 25 minutes.
Once it reached soft serve consistency,
I spooned it into my tray,
pop that in the freezer for about four hours.
Once it was completely frozen,
I scoop tiny little balls onto this baking tray and let those freeze
while I got started on making my mochi dough.
Combine some glutinous rice flour, cornstarch,
some powdered sugar, and some water.
I wanted my mochi to be pink
so I added some pink color to it before heating it up
and once it came together
I rolled it out and then took a cookie cutter to get perfect
round circles to spoon my ice cream into.
Pulled my ice cream out of the freezer
and batches so that it wouldn't melt.
Placed my tiny scoops inside the mochi and then Wrapped it all around.
The ones I was eating immediately,
I put on a plate while the others went back into the freezer.
This was absolutely divine and hit the spot.